Speaker 1: OK, this is really great stuff.
A question I've been asking for weeks now
is if you are opposed to the approved
covid-19 vaccine being required anywhere,
why aren't you opposed to a requirement for
the chicken pox vaccine or the polio or MMR
or hepatitis or whatever the case may be? FOX
News host Chris Wallace confronted the Republican
Nebraska Nebraska governor Pete Ricketts, about
exactly that question. Now Ricketts is again
loudly coming out against everything Joe Biden
is trying to do on coronavirus requirements,
including, most recently, the vaccine mandates
and requirements for employers and others.
But the very same, Pete Ricketts, is fine with
tons of other vaccines. This is fascinating
stuff. Let's watch and listen to the multiple
things that Rickett says, because we're going
to break them down one by one in a moment
Speaker 2: to attend school in your state
of Nebraska. Children must be vaccinated
against a number of diseases. Let me put
them up on the screen. They must be vaccinated
against diphtheria, tetanus and pertussis.
Speaker 1: That's the DTP shot that kids get,
Speaker 2: polio, measles, mumps and rubella,
hepatitis B and chicken pox. Why are those
mandates that parents in your state must
comply with and do comply with routinely?
Why is it that they're not so objectionable
and such a violation? Beautiful personal
freedom. But Biden's vaccine mandates are.
Well, for all those that you just
listed. There's a long history
that parents have had the opportunity to
see how those things have been implemented.
Speaker 1: So there's a long history is not
actually an argument. It might sound like an
argument, but it's not actually an argument.
He's not explaining why that should matter.
Maybe if he tried to explain, he could give us
something substantive and we might be convinced
or not, but alone. That's not an argument.
Speaker 2: And there's still a lot of people
out there who don't know what to trust. And
in fact, this is really an outcome of what
the CDC has done because they flip flop on so
many issues, whether it's mass or whether you
have to mascotry vaccine and so forth.
Speaker 1: OK, so then he says lots of
people don't know who to trust. That's also not an
argument because the question is, in either case,
with all the vaccines, they're approved by the
same body. And then the CDC has flip flopped.
This one I'm very sick of. They act like when
the CDC changes their view based on more data,
they act like it's just changing your mind about
a movie you like. I mean, listen, one day you
like the movie, you're in a different mood. The
next day you don't like it. The CDC uses science,
which is a process with with a self-correcting
mechanism built in. It becomes ideally
more accurate over time. And it's not an argument
against one vaccine, but not another. Remember,
the question was, why is this vaccine requirement
not OK? And that one is so it's in particular not
a not an argument against that.
Speaker 2: There's just a lot
of people out there who don't
know who to trust right now.
And so by having the government force
it on, you're not building a trust
where we have a trust with us on vaccines.
Speaker 1: Now, remember, it's also not being
forced. Your employer can choose
to let people test out each week
instead of being vaccinated or not. If your
employer doesn't want to, as Republicans like
Pete Ricketts want employers to be able to do
Speaker 2: this, this is a process going
to take time to bring people along. And
that's why it should be a personal choice
and not something mandated by the government.
But but forgive me, sir, I'm old enough that I
remember when the polio vaccine first came out.
A lot of us, and certainly our parents viewed
it as a blessing. And immediately I lived in New
York State at that time, the state mandated that
we all get the polio vaccine right. So, you know,
we're in the middle of a pandemic. There is a new
vaccine that Donald Trump was largely responsible
for. It's been approved full approval by the FDA.
Again, if if the polio vaccine is OK for four
parents and they have to comply with it to send
their kids to school, why not?
Speaker 1: Chris Wallace
is doing a good job here for.
Speaker 2: A lot of people, not just kids,
the vaccine for for this disease. Yeah, I think
this is very different from polio that has very
devastating effects. And certainly we know if
you're older, you know, 65 years and older,
that's where 83 percent of our deaths in Iraq.
Speaker 1: OK, so then he drops in. Well,
polio is devastating. Well, then talk about
another condition. I mean, the death rate
of chickenpox is really low. It's one per
100000. If you look at slightly older kids,
it's six per 100000. It's very contagious, but
it's not very deadly. So the point here is he
has no good answer. And this is a question we've
been asking for a while. Look at all these other
requirements for vaccination. They're only talking
at most ninety nine point nine percent of them
are only talking about the covid vaccine
requirement. They are pathetic. They don't
have an answer that they're able to articulate.
If they can come up with an actual substantive
explanation, I would gladly review it and
think about it and maybe they will convince me.